a lot of cats
are liberals who vote right to cowed to
say so out loud
a study out of a new york university go
cold sores
what is wrong with me finds that america
is more liberal than it was 50 years ago
yet voting for more republicans those
liberal nyu researchers concluded their
research by jumping out of an eighth
story window
and you laugh you're disgusting
researchers looked at a pile of data and
turns out from 70 1972 to 2004 party
affiliation has shifted steadily toward
republicans even as each generation is
just a little more liberal than its
predecessor with more tolerance in areas
the left claims are worse than ever like
race gender and personal freedom at this
rate in a few years the gop ticket will
be rand paul and rupaul
and i'm going to vote for that
so if our country sees more liberal
attitudes with each generation
why haven't liberals dominated the
elections is this because wokism has
contaminated traditional liberalism so
liberals see that republicanism is
closer to reality or maybe it's because
liberals like the nutty ideas of the
squad in theory but not when it comes
out of their own paychecks and they also
know that extremists in the party will
cancel them out the moment they reveal
that they might have any diversity of
thought
so they lie about their preferences even
bill maher noted recently that quote
woke is something that is not an
extension of liberalism it's very often
the opposite of what an old school
liberal like me believes but really who
knows how many liberals out there are
voting republican but hide it in their
daily life
well look i mean i'm no republican but i
just think that when it comes to school
choice maybe you know
[Music]
let's get a cup of coffee we can talk
there
well like i was saying i voted democrat
my whole life i just think that parents
should have a bigger role
[Music]
let's go someplace more quiet
look all i'm saying is that maybe
possibly school vouchers could be a
viable alternative in some situations
[Music]
yeah we do so much with so little it's
quite impressive i'd say
all right curtis you know what drives me
nuts about this is i don't see this is
good news but it's also infuriating
because
they bash they publicly bash the things
that they support privately meanwhile
there are people like us that take the
slings and the arrows of actually saying
what we're going to do or think
and in my case
bullets hollow point bullets but
look that makes you holier than thou
exactly
and having survived thank you yes but
libertarians and liberals have a lot in
common they really do when it comes to
social issues true there's they converge
unlike progressives and conservatives
who are at war with one another but if
you were to say to a liberal hey you got
a lot in common with the libertarians
and vice versa they would say no we
don't no we don't but you do
so in social issues gays lesbians
transgenders we can go the whole route
they have more than in common than they
do being at odds and they recognize that
for a lot of these social issues that's
not important
and that's why they're veering towards
the gop at least those have been my
experiences having been a libertarian
for month or sundays yeah that's true
you know uh susan it's really about it
one it's really about economics right
you can have a freer life right if you
are a capitalist
like a republican card carrying
capitalists right here but i did
something dangerous over christmas and i
actually talked to politics at christmas
eve maybe that was not recommended but i
would say that most america is right
down the middle as you said they're
tolerant on social issues but at the end
of the day they want to be able to feed
their family for food on the table and
actually card carrying democrats are not
on the side of the squad so they think
that's really just extreme left so i
think america is very similar in many
ways whether you're liberal or you're
conservative you know what it is it's
because we're getting tricked by the
kind of the twitter element of this that
we only see
the loudest voices and we and we forget
and actually this is what cnn we talked
about in the earlier segment that we
actually miss out the fact that america
is not even remotely interested in a lot
of this crap that we make a big deal out
of or specifically what you make a big
deal out of
i know that america is not interested in
a lot of the same things as i am
but i believe in an america where nobody
has to be interested in the same things
that i am yes i mean i personally i'm i
guess considered extremely liberal on
social issues but that means i basically
just don't think the government should
be involved in anything that's in
anyone's personal life or any you know
transactions that are consensual between
adults um but people just adults yes i
don't think that kids i don't believe in
baby drug dealers you're baby drug
dealers yeah you need to be over 18
before you can be a drug dealer oh you
know what you know you try hard yeah
that's where i draw the line yes no kid
drug dealer yes yes yes
i don't think there are any yes or very
few
um but honestly i i but people sometimes
give me a like a hard time they don't
want to talk about what you can agree on
they just say oh you work at fox news
therefore you're bad you're a bad person
i am a bad person but not because i work
here i know it's true it's true don't
blame us for your degradation
box said she was disgusting before she
got here
if anything you slightly improved being
at fox well i don't know if i've
improved but i've tried to keep some of
the worst things off the air having a
regular job for you has got you to bathe
regularly that's true i don't wash my
hair when i'm not at work
leave a hat on yes exactly
that's uh you know emily i also think
that the the reason why you're seeing a
lot of liberals
veer towards republican voting is
because their own party is leaving them
the woke-ism has kind of infected their
their their world and it's like okay i'm
just not going to tell these people what
i'm doing but i'm voting for so and so
does that make sense to you yeah i think
that's a great point and i also think
that this study focused on voting and in
terms of society on the whole moving
more toward the liberal side that's been
decided largely in the courts right
that's not really what you vote on but
what you vote on and what this study
found people care about and what is is
um having and drawing the left to vote
republican is government oversight and
healthcare and the second amendment
and others and those fundamental bedrock
um issues of the republican party among
others are crucial and especially the
the more we go the more we have
presidents like biden who are just
spending like
astronomical amounts who are growing the
federal government astronomical sizes
then that is why people are voting
republican because they don't want the
government regulating everything and
making you forcing you to believe a
certain way and act a certain way and
the like so and i don't think babies
should be able to buy drugs either
that's you know i'm glad because we're
gonna have to do an on-air apology
tomorrow
about that but you know what's it you
know what i find refreshing and then
we'll move on is when you meet somebody
who doesn't
fulfill like they could be
they something left and something right
so they could be pro second amendment
but anti-death penalty right you know
and it's like so like you know what you
mean free agents yes agents and it's all
the form of what you hinted on it's all
part of political technology we get
tricked yeah we're all free spirits yes
i can agree with you on which one issue
with you another and then all of a
sudden believe it or not aoc all-out
crazy alexandria ocasio-cortez that does
not make me
judas
i'm a free agent with my own thought
process exactly and somehow those are
endangered and on that note hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else